let's move on to our next topic shall we
because as we heard earlier in the show
new research by the university of
bristol suggests climate change
discussions are still dominated by white
men and it's something that
environmentalists and campaign groups
have come under fire for in the past so
is the climate change movement
unrepresentative
and joycelyn this comes from a year-long
study in bristol doesn't it it found
that
voices of ethnically diverse people make
up just three percent of discussions on
climate exchange decision making
you have founded a company called uh
climate in color i think one of the
things you're trying to do is try to
make sure that conversations are more
diverse so are you surprised by this
finding
no of course not i'm not surprised by
this finding because the inequality that
we see in other
parts of life other industries is not
any different in the climate space but i
think that a key thing to keep in mind
is
where we are kind of looking at these
discussions because through my work um
people of color women and people from
marginalized communities are actually on
the front line of these issues on the
front line of the effects of these
issues but also at the front line and
leading action in many ways so when we
say that there's a lack of diversity in
climate change discussions i think we
need to think about where those
discussions are happening because it
seems like there's a huge disparity
between on the ground grassroots and
frontline
representation of marginalized
communities and then sort of
institutional organizational and
governmental conversations and i think
there is where we see a huge issue
bruce what's the situation like in the
states
uh it's exactly as you're describing um
in the uk which is um
we have historically made a lot of
decisions that are by a very small part
of society and we now know and we're
seeing policies beginning to put in
place to actually address this so in
california for example
recently law was passed that no longer
can the boards of corporations be all
men and all white
and so how do we open up decision making
so as jocelyn said particularly for
people who are the most affected we will
make better decisions
and more durable decisions if we're
involving the very people who are
impacted by
um being on the front lines of this
climate crisis
what do you make joycelyn of steps like
that how do you think we should address
this
well um i think there's a really
important quote by thomas sankara which
i can paraphrase but
the inclusion of marginalized
communities is not one that's out of
charity it's because it is a real
necessary basis for a kind of triumph
and success in overcoming the climate
emergency um these people are not just
victims they're not people that we have
to include because of charity they're
actually
so creative and so dedicated i'm out of
in a lot of um times
necessity um so really our success will
be built on the inclusion i mean it's it
is a necessity rather than a sort of
charitable action and justin a very
quick thought on cop 26 coming up how
confident are you that a diverse range
of voices will be heard there
i think um that that will depend on
which zone you're in
i think the blue zone not so much
there are huge barriers
from the uk home office and from
vaccines and all of these different
barriers financial barriers
in the green zone there are a huge
amount of events we've got cop 26
coalition doing such amazing work so
many activist groups are going to be
there and that's where the real
diversity is going to stand out in my
opinion
you